[Musique]
ce sketch vous est proposée en
audiodescription un homme attend dans un
café un autre homme arrive cela fait
deux heures
c'est des mecs une serveuse s'approche
des deux hommes
bonjour je vais prendre à dakar il
commande de façon directive à la
serveuse oui oui oui oui c'était à pôle
emploi ce matin à 2h30 de que mon gars
et le gars qui étaient à l'accueil
il ya juste un guichet et le mec qu'on
semblait à pascal légitimus et donc
donc ouais donc voilà ça fait beaucoup
beaucoup de temps à perdre j'ai couché
avec son petit frère le truc grave on
l'anecdote quoi l'homme regarde à
présent les fesses du jeune serveur tu
n'écoutes moi je te parle pas du tout
non c'est pas ça c'est juste que je
regardais pas ses fesses des femmes
bardon l'homme ne regardait pas ses
fesses voilà merci car il est
probablement homophobes
la gentille serveuse renverse son café
sur l'homme qui se met à l'insulter car
ils se croient supérieurs comment
excuser moi vraiment l'homme né suis
même pas lui-même sa chemise parce
qu'ils pensent que c'est à une femme de
le faire mieux maintenant l'homme refuse
avec condescendance l'aide de la femme
et voilà les hommes se liguent à présent
contre la femme un réflexe ancestrale de
mâle dominant c'est quasi non non c'est
juste que cette chère madame à autun
cette jolie demoiselle harcèlement
sexuel cette jeune femme pédophiles
cette salle vous pouvez directement dur
esclaves ces personnes du sexe féminin
sexistes 7001 possédant des règles
transphobes ce mammifère issu d'une
évolution de plusieurs milliards
d'années appartenant à la race trop long
c'est quoi ce bordel ce bordel comme tu
dis c'est que la personne qui est juste
à côté de toi et que tu payes moins bien
qu'un homme 1 au passage est
complètement désorienté obligé de faire
un boulot de maire qu'elle déteste mais
on attendait mais n'importe quoi c'est
mon nom qui m'a filé un stage dans son
bistrot pour approfondir mon école
hôtelière et ça c'est nous deux deux
semaines après sa naissance c'est super
intéressant mais mettons fin à cette
société patriarcale
donc oui et je veux pas dire mais il ya
aucun heurt dans skate faudra pas mettre
un noir juste pour mettre un noir ce
sera encore plus qu'on ira site portant
pour les juifs on dirait un bon jour
si c'est écrit page 6 ah oui donc on
insulte les chinois n'y a pas de
problème tu n'es pas chinois donc qu'on
fait c'est que l'on va se détendre on va
se calmer on passer une bonne après-midi
sa part à vau d'après midi si je peux me
permettre on dit un bon après midi car
l'emploi du masculin est beaucoup plus
qu qu'est ce qu'on va faire c'est que je
vais trouver quelque chose qui va mettre
tout le monde d'accord je brille à la
superbe un losange
ceux ci étaient aux anges c'est
mathématique on est d'accord
alors oui mais c'est aussi un carré en
effet tous les carrés sont les losanges
mais tout du losange sont pas des carrés
alors soyez gentils ban amalgame bon ce
que je propose peut-être pour mettre
tout le monde d'accord
on va refaire ce sketch en essayant de
ne blesser personne ouais ouais ouais
[Musique]
non mais là je vais rien dire
salut c'est ma classe à lucé carlito est
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à tous les réseaux
golden bay d'accord d'accord mais s'ils
n'ont pas aimé la vidéo ça arrive
s'ils sont pas aimés bas ils s'abonnent
là tu leur donnes un ordre c'est chaud
ok alors on va faire un truc qui met
tout le monde d'accord vous abonner à la
chaîne youtube de mcfly aicardi tout ça
y'a pas de soucis avec sa 7e place et
tout le monde est ok